alors on va s'arrêter quelques quelques
instants arrêtons nous quelques instants
sur le travail de prospection des
couturiers la vente au lendemain des
collections dépend du bien vouloir de
quelques milliers de personnes une
clientèle très restreinte pour un marché
de la haute couture qui pèse très lourd
2 milliards cinq cent soixante millions
de francs en quête de lloba grégoire
cette robe de cocktail en coton de chez
nina ricci a nécessité 60 heures de
travail
elle coûte 32 mille francs qui va
l'acheter sans doute quelques-unes des
3000 cliente particulière que se
partagent 22 maisons couture peu de
françaises
beaucoup de femmes arabes qui feront
leur choix sur cassette vidéo
certaines américaine mais leur nombre
varie selon les fluctuations du dollar
blé de l'arrêt base aussi nous devons
choisir maintenant très attentivement
les modèles et surtout ne pas faire de
food inc actuellement les défilés c'est
le prestige l'image du couturier à
travers le monde
mais cela ne suffit pas à faire vivre
une grande maison d'élections comme
cette vous avez vu vous offre 5 et 6
millions de nouveaux fonds et évidemment
que tout ça devrait s'amortir sûr que
trois ou quatre cents europe le moment
baleines et voyez ces toxines
impraticable par contre dès que vous
entrez dans le domaine du parfum du prêt
à porter des foulards bijoux fantaisie
c'est d'ailleurs avec ce genre d'article
que la maison nina ricci réalise 65 % de
son chiffre d'affaires